you know what's funny actually you got
me to say something I haven't said I
sent to my mommy over there I feel so
guilty that my mom was so awesome that I
want to be that for other people hmm you
know like I feel like I got so lucky
that I almost have to give back to
everybody and play that role and I can't
to the level my mom did for me but if I
can play a little bit of that role to
the market to the people that are
watching right now well then I've
accomplished something like if there's
somebody right now in the chat I can't
see the chat who like like can tangibly
feel like something that I put out in
the world affected them in a positive
manner that feels good and I almost feel
like it's my destiny because i have to
pay back that that's what happened to me
and I got lucky that person was my mom
for me so pain she with your mom's gonna
be a real legacy yeah I think that's
probably right no question i mean like
there you know I you know you've heard
me you know I love talking about legacy
like it seems like there's about forty
seven things that are now my legacy and
that's right right which is like for
every what you and that's true that like
honestly at some level um everybody
who's watching right now or anybody who
ever watches and I bring value to like
my legacy my reputation will be
different for everybody right like he'll
be different for everybody and you know
I like that it's a very um it's equally
a very humble thing as it is a vanity
thing for me like I pull it both sides
of the extremes on this issue like I am
I want the vanity of like the attention
in the admiration and the selfies on the
street but I also um I'm just so
grateful and thankful and humbled that I
can make an impact on people's lives